this is a picture of my mother my
younger brother who is in the U.S right
now and this is my an Eid party at Hamid
mahmund's family home in Kabul in August
2021 two weeks before the Taliban
toppled the civilian government
could you see the signs
yes but I didn't expect it to happen in
like two weeks I was thinking maybe this
takes like probably another year at
least
but after months of fighting the Taliban
returned to power on August 15th anyone
with ties to the U.S was now considered
an Enemy of the State the Biden
Administration promised to help those
who worked with the Americans during 20
years of war you have heard us say for
the better part of a year now that the
United States has an enduring commitment
not only to the people of Afghanistan
but of course to American citizens to
lawful permanent residents
some 1300 of whom we have
helped transport
out of Afghanistan over the course of uh
the past year but uh also to uh Afghans
to whom we have a special commitment the
U.S has resettled more than 80 000
Afghans but critics say many more are
still in limbo that's because the US's
immigration system wasn't designed to
handle thousands of emergency residency
permits Refugee applications and visas
to those who worked with the U.S
military all at the same time in order
for any of these three Pathways to work
there needs to be a plan to get people
out and moving out and that plan is
going to need significant political
backing by the administration it needs
to be the highest priority otherwise
it's not going to happen
mahmund an American citizen for more
than 10 years used his connections to
help his brother Escape during the final
days of the U.S military evacuation
now he's trying to bring his fiancee and
his mother a former girls school
principal to the U.S
she helped you a service woman in
Afghanistan in Logan Province helped the
PRT from Czech Republic
she was the director of women's Affair
defended the democratic values that
America was promoting there
the women have been living in a
temporary shelter and Qatar since April
no one can tell them when they can fly
to the U.S mahmund has a message for the
Secretary of State if I'm That official
and I tell you under process we don't
know if and when this is going to be
done
how would you feel about it
a call to the U.S to help Hamid
malchman's family and every other Afghan
family fearful about life under Taliban
rule Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera
Washington